hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
entrepreneur mastery today I want to
talk about how to choose the right
business idea before getting started
though I wanted to have a quick word
about failure most entrepreneurs fail if
you look at the stats something like
eighty percent of new entrepreneurs fail
within the first couple years of
starting their business and that's a
huge number it doesn't mean you're bad
entrepreneur chances are it's a bad idea
and so with this presentation today I
want to walk you through the steps that
you need to take to pick the winning
business idea if you failed in the past
don't let that stop you some of the
world's most famous entrepreneurs failed
when they first got started and it was
until they hit on their winning business
idea that they got to success so bear
with me we're gonna have some fun today
here's a classic example Milton Hershey
so dedicated entrepreneur was working
14-hour days he started off in the
caramel business so he started in
Philadelphia his hometown started his
business would make caramels overnight
and then sell them during the day the
business did okay but then he couldn't
make his payments it ultimately failed
so moved to Denver started the same
business up again same story failed he
moved to Chicago same story failed who
the New Orleans same story and then he
moved in New York and finally after
giving it a try in New York one day a
bunch of kids stole all his inventory he
was out of money he failed again so here
was a dedicated entrepreneur you know he
was really working at it wasn't for lack
of effort tried in five different cities
the same concept and it didn't work and
then he thought to himself you know
maybe caramels that's not a winning
business idea maybe there's something
better that I should be going after and
that's when he discovered chocolate and
the rest is history harvest in Hershey
from her she's chocolates so you know he
would had the whole systems in place he
just had the wrong business idea from
the start and it was until he switched
his course to pick a winning business
idea that I was able to achieve the
success that he had so let's talk about
these four steps to success
and hopefully this will help guide you
to create the venture that will make you
an all star entrepreneur
you